really interesting interview on The
Young Turks were jancuga interviewed
senator Elizabeth Warren Massachusetts
Democrat Elizabeth Warren about a number
of issues and she's considered I guess
is it fair to say she's the second most
progressive senator like Bernie would be
the most progressive and then it's
Elizabeth Warren is that I think even
jenk asked her that and it seems like
she's number two yeah yeah so I think
that's a fair thing to say so Jen cast a
reasonable question which is why didn't
you come out in support of Bernie
Sanders during the Democratic primary
last year an Elizabeth Warren I love
Elizabeth Warren we've had her in studio
great things I could say all day about
Elizabeth Warren with peace and love but
this is kind of a bizarre answer take a
listen to this of course you know the
person most widely considered to be the
most romantic senator is Bernie Sanders
so a natural question is why not back
him during the 2016 primaries if you two
are the closest aligned involved so look
I think that that our our primary I
thought was a good thing and I thought
it was good that Bernie was out there
that Hillary was out there they were
giving two different visions they were
out there through all the states I
thought it put both energy on our psyche
I'll tell you something else I thought
it did it made me proud to be a Democrat
you know while the Republicans were
doing their clown car thing you know
with who was going to be voted off the
island and then of course ended up with
a reality star as their as their
standard there I was proud of white
Democrats we're out there talking about
how it was the right thing to do
and in the end uh when uh when it was
time I went out there and and fought
once it was resolved to try to get
Hillary elected and I would have done
the same for Bernie no doubt about so
sometimes it's really useful to actually
look on at the words of what was said
here so let's put it up on the screen
again the question was why didn't you
support Bernie Sanders during the
primaries and what Elizabeth Warren says
is number one I think that our primary
was a good thing that's not an answer
that's just not an answer number two
I thought it was good that Bernie and
Hillary were out there with two visions
well you can support their being two
visions and still decide to help one
candidate over the other if their vision
aligns more with yours number three it
made me proud to be a Democrat during
the Republican clown car primary not an
answer to the question and also we're
going to talk about number three a
little bit more in a second number four
I was proud of what Democrats were
talking about and it was the right thing
to do
not an answer number five in the end
when it was time I went out there and
fought once it was resolved to help
Hillary and number six I would have done
the same for Bernie Sanders
I like Elizabeth Warren I do I've
interviewed her this is not an answer
and jenk tried to follow up too and
here's how that one uh when it was time
I went out there and and fought once it
was resolved to try to get Hillary
elected and I would have done the same
for Bernie no doubt about do you get why
some progressives are still mad about
that that Massachusetts was decided by
one point three points Iowa was decided
by point three that perhaps he could
have helped him put a put him over the
top and then he would have won Iowa New
Hampshire on us and there are people who
see it the other way you know for me I
think about it this way there is nothing
the Republicans would love better than
for us to stand around and shoot at each
other this is not about attacking
Elizabeth Warren's politics okay again
she is the second most progressive
senator in uh in the Senate and that is
something that we should be supporting I
would respect Elizabeth Warren more and
understand this more if she had said
something else ideally the truth
whatever it was right maybe it's hey you
know what I calculated that it would
have been met bad for my political
career to come out now and support one
candidate over the other I decided to
wait until it was resolved or it might
have been hey I agreed to stay out of
the primary either because someone asked
her that Hillary the DNC whoever we
don't know or she could have said I
genuinely didn't think that Bernie could
win and by the time it seemed like maybe
he could win
I felt it wasn't a good idea to be to
get involved whatever anything is better
than no answer at all yeah I think the
actual answer there
is that she like pretty much everyone
else thought Hillary Clinton was going
to be the Democratic nominee and then
she wanted to position herself well in
her administration if she was to win
perhaps even be her vice president which
we she was considered for yeah so any
anything at what Pat is suggesting what
I think anything would have been a
better answer than not giving an answer
now I want to drill down on number three
if we can put that back up just for a
second Pat number two part three of
Elizabeth Warren's explanation which was
not an explanation is it made me proud
to be a Democrat during the Republican
clown car primary um I don't know how
anyone who watched the Democratic
primary could come away proud about what
happened corporate Democrats using every
opportunity they could to prevent Bernie
Sanders from really having a fair shot
the debate times and the initial
schedule of debates although ultimately
the DNC couldn't hold back and more
debates were scheduled scheduling
debates on Sunday night of three-day
weekends and and uh impacting voting
times even in during during some
primaries I don't know how anyone could
have watched that uh disaster the
utterly abortive Democratic primary that
took place and say that made me proud to
be a Democrat I'm not a Democrat I've
never been a Democrat or a Republican I
was embarrassed by how the Democrats ran
that primary it's really not even so
clear as to if there's a contentious
primary if that means that the person
that comes out of it will have a better
or worse chance of winning the general
election right so in 2008 John McCain
won that nomination of the Republicans
pretty easily yep Obama and Hillary was
a lot more contentious and of course
Obama won I think that there is this
idea from some in the establishment
Democratic Party that you want your hand
that it's sailed through the primary
process because it will help them in the
in the eventual national election
there's no reason to think that that's
true ends us I don't think that that's
the primary motivator behind the DNC
effectively uniting to hurt Bernie
Sanders and help Hillary Clinton so I
don't know why we didn't just get an
answer to the question from Elizabeth
Warren but we didn't get an answer and
I'm glad that Genk at least attempted to
follow up there